[MUSIC PLAYING]
This episode of "Shots of Awe"
is brought to you by Toyota.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So I'm fascinated by the
paradoxical function of art.
There's that great
line that says,
art is the lie that
reveals the truth.
This paradoxical
nature, the fact
that art speaks to kind
of deeper ecstatic truth.
It goes beyond empirical truth.
It goes beyond empirical
reality and scratches
at the very edges of our psyche,
digs deeply into our soul.
It appeals to that
space of archetype,
dream, of myth, of metaphor.
Right?
It's like Werner
Herzog used to say,
facts are not the most
interesting thing in the world.
If facts were the most
interesting thing in the world,
then go buy the phone book.
It's full of facts.
What we're interested
in is ecstatic truth,
[INAUDIBLE] wrote about,
reveals deeper truths
than a journalist's
more literal grid.
In other words, the artist gets
us somewhere beyond the factual
and somehow reveals the truth.
There's something kind of
beautiful about that idea,
and I think that's
the function of art,
to communicate with
us at that depth,
and thus, worth celebrating.
[MUSIC PLAYING]